thunderhorse one time control one minute
war zone rated 50 players out of 150 so
far average rating 1786 time and
position handicapped so that trying even
things out we adjusted according to
rating anybody could enter no experience
level required coming up in five four
three two one
tournament on alrighty what are we gonna
have here give me this little thing
uh-oh not again
no way don't even start this stuff I
better get points here give me the error
message I want fish in for the air if
anything the long-awaited thunderlord's
what a start
whoa come on are other people paired up
oh yeah now they do as soon as I go away
double the points ah man what a waste
what a waste I better get this one now
you scared be very scared black I'm
coming after you uh-oh come on Knight do
something a little bit more aggressive
actually Oh what's this what's what's
what's the Queen don't okay kill the
bishop kill the bishop oh they stop that
I could Castle remember I could Castle
Oh
maybe there's that glitch right I'm
gonna have to try that move stop that
pawns advance I'm playing down a rook
why'd I open this position up they're
not moving quick though I'm just gonna
go back and forth I don't know what to
do sneaky sneaky sneaky
ah my rook is shuffling the shuffle I'm
hitting black with the rook shuffle
right here it's not gonna be a dry is it
okay let's go upon each pawn enough
dancing okay now one more dance let's
come back actually alright let's do this
avoid in exchange okay I gain some time
coming back let's do this my knight
wants to go somewhere Oh
watch I'm gonna do the castle II move
you're gonna see a move that it's
impossible to make unless you're in the
Thunder Horse queenside castle you ready
for this
coming up boom
there it is did my opponents my
opponents did it freeze again wait a
second I think I see a glitch oh I think
there might be a glitch wait a second
okay here we go
there might be something there oh I'm
gonna use it to my advantage
oh I'm gonna use all the tactics all the
tactics okay I can't do it right now
because I don't I have both drugs oh I
just dropped my Brooke what did I do
oh are you kidding me there's no coming
back from this I was too focused on
trying to get in sneaky stuff oh man
there's no way I could win this I'm down
so much material I got a shuffle again
he said in the chat everyday I'm
shufflin I got a shuffle shuffle shuffle
shuffle pick up a piece no no trades hit
the Queen oh I didn't mean to do that I
didn't mean to do that
I'm in trouble I'm in trouble come on
come on come on come back to my fun oh
man this is bad news bad news bears hit
the
if I get this I'll go crazy
Pinsky Pinsky you must be afraid be
afraid be very afraid hit the Queen
again they're burning time they were
gonna play Knight they're trouble I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble 22 come on come
on come on come on each file each file
each file you can do it each file attack
you could do it pawn push scare the
night defend upon oh man this is so bad
Oh everything is hit everything is hit
defend the Knights in a pin
I got a pond what's the time situation I
don't want to Queen trade stop it stop
it right here how much time how much
time eight gotta go quicker okay I just
got to do a pond um something or other I
could have taken that night why don't I
take tonight Queen trade mate mate mate
I've got a primo stuff free move I got
the Queen give a check I don't have any
time
oh I'm down on time oh this is so bad oh
I had my opportunities okay I want to be
starting out without the Queen rook this
is how I'm gonna win games oh don't
leave yet okay stay focused now I was
that's that's um remember that
okay I blended a bunch of pieces when I
when I first realized I first realized
that um I could actually win games by
queenside castling King one to see one
it's a game it's a game changer right
there be prepared
all that ponds dead let's do this first
though okay
okay I'm not gonna lose any more
incoming night recapture I have control
of everything
ah that's a bad one to lose okay now you
could do this I lost seventeen hundred
pieces quit exaggerating okay check and
then me I got this I got this h7 this is
the quick win that I needed I'm in check
get out of there I got mate next you
can't stop it matin - that's me that's
me doctor chairman for you could two
pips come on give me no Queen rook no
Queen rook no Queen rook ah no Queen
night man I want no Queen rook and I'm
gonna win the game I'm gonna do that
move as soon as possible I'm gonna try
and get the castling move in and that's
it what a wonderful defense wait do you
see it's gonna happen very soon Bishop
takes here ok let's support that defend
see 5 c4 I should have won that game I
should have started pre moving sooner
I was floundering I was making Knight
moves with my queen and all that bad
stuff
let's guard here I'm dropping this
though that happens oh that happens - I
just had have to take that hopefully I
could still get this one I can't afford
another loss there's no way absolutely
no way I have to I have to do better
than that I can't allow that
okay what's happening right here I'm in
a pin they're down on time pawn push get
rid that night that night is to go you
gotta get out of here night he's gonna
go somewhere else okay let's do this and
then push push push
let's try that they're gonna pin ok
defend I'm on the bishop
oh okay rook you want to do something
they're down at time mm-hmm
so why oh it's scary time scary over
here
I just dropped upon another one what am
i doing
get over here King can't be easy just
can't be easy looking for mates tricky
mates move bishop here or something I
gotta take this what's the clock out
okay I gotta try this
no avoid the rook exchange no works for
you no trades flight square flight
square huh don't tell me what do we have
oh no oh no no no no no I got it back to
term at 10 all somebody has 29 don't
give me a Queen rook I don't want a
Queen rook no Queen rook no Queen rook
come on this is the only way I'm gonna
win and I have to hope that it actually
is a glitch ah thank you give me a queen
rook I wonder if that's actually gonna
work let's go here oh they're not moving
okay this could be a pretty quick win
then I can't believe I dropped a bishop
a rook a knight oh man that left that
Bishop went into pac-man more than that
game the knight moved there was tension
between ambitious when I see that I'm in
14th place I'm not even on the charts
here I'm off the charts in a bad way I'm
in a bad way off the charts
20 minutes look at the clock doesn't
that make you nervous look at that
you try that the clock ticking right in
your face 20 and change this guy's not
moving strong pine is not moving what's
going on elsewhere games who is somebody
that mm this guy okay this is the guy
just played who's gonna win this one I
don't know I better go back to my game
it's starting real soon less than 10 it
better not be my clock that's moving
right here let's go let's go let's go
c'mon give me the points give me the
points give me the points give me the
points yes floor more I got 14 I have a
mountain to climb still 29 his first no
Queen rook man yes a quick resigner they
were fearing the Phantom Queen side
minor pieces okay no Queen rook I needed
that boost
there's 78 players at this point by the
way no Queen rook just don't give me a
rook oh it's my move it's my move and
watch out watch out watch out watch out
for what there it is again
sneaky sneaky sneaky I tell you what
look at these players being sneaky is
that Knight gonna move too he is I'm
gonna take him though
and now large the H pond is being
launched whoa I better Castle and get
connected and now no what is that Queen
up to get out of there Queen I'm gonna
start gaining some space more space
everybody loves space pawn push Queens
trapped soon I think right here
no no trades how much time defend I'd
lost my bishop let me take that night on
f4 he's out of plague sort of let's get
out of nonsense pawn push take that pawn
give me something to play for
oh I didn't really want him to take that
it's open he was listening he wasn't
listening okay wait I have something on
the B file Oh Oh the Knights going down
is he going down to flames down in
flames Queen right here
Oh that's what I needed
that's what I needed
Oh where's the main pigs to pigs to pigs
check
oh this isn't leading to me I need an
accurate move where the accurate moves
oh go there it's better isn't it
um right here my I might have to walk a
tightrope oh I'm in trouble
capture the pond how much time do I have
I don't have any time oh they're gonna
capture the pond now can I defend is
this defendable what do I got what I got
what I got
oh I'm be I'm be another loser I'm a
dead man
uh why did I allow this I'm dead there's
no way I could dodge 1,700 checks no way
no way no way I'm dead
seventeen there's no way I'm in 15th
place that's two games don't give me a
queen Brooke that's the only chance I
have are they onto my the little
glitching scheme I have going on I need
to win those games I can't be losing
those ah man two games okay I gotta go
with what works best
let's close this up what works I don't
even know what works best anymore oh
that doesn't work best let's get this oh
man a pin no no let's go let's close it
up
close it up and then break it down
bishop here I want to get on the dark
squares here okay that King is fleeing
he's fleeing everybody's on to my sneaky
tricks open this up oh why did I do that
over here King I need my dark square
bishop to do something but it's not
doing anything I just dropped a rook oh
yeah it's not my tournament or is it
sneaky night check grab upon oh oh oh oh
they should be scared are they scared
let's try this
uh-oh bishop check bishop check if the
rook like this oh oh
check may may coming up soon
that's me that's me that's me that's
what I needed back to turn with 29 15
minutes left that guy is 70 can I at
least get them come on no look no ponds
these are tough ones to win - oh man Man
Man Man Man
f7 I should be piling up on f7 that
Bishop has to get out of there get out
of there Bishop I can't deal with you no
way you gotta go okay
I just dropped that pond no I didn't pin
pile up on the pins Knight move the
knight trouble weaknesses I could take
it this is a brutal pin this could be a
quick win resignation time making two
threat uh-oh trouble 1 and then 2 coming
up there's just like computer moves ok
that's me that was kind of quick back to
term at 43 don't you dare count me out
I'm up there I'm in the top 3 no Queen
rook man I want to be able to get that
in that's gonna be like a buzzer-beater
move a game like that where I start off
with that and my opponents clock just
ticks and they don't know what a them I
think there's a glitch that's a glitch
don't let anybody know about that that's
gonna be the Thunder Horse secret now I
don't really want to do that I don't
want to open up the files and stuff I'm
gonna have to or something right it's
gonna open up how's the clock situation
okay it's decent
it's decent don't let anybody know about
that one keep it hush-hush
don't let anybody know okay my Knights
gonna go for he's gonna travel he's a
traveler okay I'm gonna I'm gonna grab
this pond Oh for the best actually I'm
looking for a mate and - I might have it
no I don't I want that night to move and
I could push here something how they're
neutralizing my bishop neutralizer
they neutralize me right there I was
neutralized oh I got to pick up
something oh boy I better come over here
and defend this pond I'm in trouble
trouble trouble trouble Oh defend the
Knights gonna come here Oh brutal it's
brutal
it's a brutal position I'm gonna have to
try it hopefully I have a deadly I do
have something deadly right here not
deadly but and get some material back at
least oh man oh man oh come on
tick tick tick tick just let their clock
right now there's no way I could afford
another last no trades Oh rook check or
the rook is gonna kill my queen I have
to abandon it run run for the hills okay
I got this my king KITT run fast
over here King where it's safe over here
King it's safe defend get the Queen
actually I should chase the night no I
got this gonna take here clock out over
here over here how much time time
brainer time burner just in time time
burner match tournament 88 66-59 I'm
coming back coming back it's hard to win
all these games okay and by the way I'm
the only one that would actually start
out most likely with without a rook
that's a good thing okay let's keep it
close keep it close keep it closed
easy does it okay now I know where the
king is living he's living over here and
the G files ready to open up G file give
me the G file over here G file light
squares light squares light squares gets
it to light squares
okay h6 is going down h6 is going down
be prepared no Knight don't you dare go
there no okay that's gonna be taken pile
up on this king up bishop owl
right here uh-oh I'm on this a lot oh
the queen is dead mate coming up real
soon we're not okay this is this is a
one game
let's take here and then come over in
this direction no push this pawn he's
passed push right here push again okay
they resigned back to tournament 77 108
77 come Oh
let's go let's go oh they're not giving
me no Queen night ah those are the ones
that can maybe help me out the most
don't give me the card I mean the Queen
rook no Queen rook mm they're on to me
they're on to me here okay let's do this
we're gonna have a pawn push yes we are
Oh alrighty then
oh boy scary it's very scary over here
it's very very scary you guys got to get
out of here this bishop has to go that
you have to go tonight
and oh man I gotta get rid of this this
is too nuts okay I need some breathing
space here I got it
okay the Queen's I guess have to come
off Wow this position got opened up and
I didn't want to have to have it opened
up tonight right there it might be good
actually
uh-oh my king is gonna go after the
bishop he's a fighting piece the King is
a fighting piece use it check I should
have done this earlier actually let's
come over here oh oh oh I should've
taken the bishop check that's me that's
me that's me back to tournament 108 97 9
and change
blue chicken yes I'm gonna blue chicken
the chicken I don't that means what'd I
just say I don't know what I just said
mate in 1 2 3 here it goes this game
over game over
let's work it's working
Oh
the king Siwon they don't know hit them
it's probably not showing that I moved
on their screen this is cruel unusual
cruel and very very unusual
okay you know what time it is time to do
some home prep I got that one
kinky one to see one tkl oh man it's
pandemonium here they didn't know hit
them they have no idea what just hit
them the blue chicken is looking around
like why is a white movement
oh I snuffed out the little glitch right
here came to see one Oh
tick-tick-tick blue chicken is
scratching his head where are we
understandings Oh 106 this is gonna
propel me into first it's a mating six a
mating six right here yes 20 points 117
take advantage of it well it's there
okay you can't have it all the time can
you
oh is that bad to be doing that should I
be doing that no is it okay to do that
oh I can't help it I think that's funny
they don't know what hit them
oh the rook is dead the rook is cooked
oh I'm back in the game here at this
clean time though Jam is the only thing
I have time five time I think I have it
oh give a check
Oh take a bishop he's free okay the
Queen is running wild here it's just
time that I have to be concerned about
grab a pond I'm on the night
should I be doing that is somebody gonna
tell just Cubao me don't you dare come
on this is the thunderhorse there's no
rules
it's the no rules Thunder hoards
tournament Queen check time burners kill
the bishop right here what are we gonna
have
I should probably play a rook here let
me do that instead they're not moving oh
maybe Bishop there was good actually
okay this is close to me real close to
me I could have just taken her up oh I'm
gonna do it anyhow just time burners no
time no time no time
pigs turn 137 129 they're right on my
heel 129 126 no no fries ah fry okay
okay okay okay
efore f7 I'm getting Nona fried what's
this oh man I'm getting Nona fried
that's all right I'm gonna get the
points though right what's the UM this
is how much time is left five minutes
and change 5 24 23 22 they're not moving
I'm getting Nona fried again 137 129
what's going on with these guys I
already have a pre move in these guys
are ready to win they're gonna pass me
any second this guy's up there right
here this guy is he ready to win come on
Black is my game going no 17 seconds is
black and a win black could maybe still
win Oh black isn't gonna win him there
goes the Queen and the bishop and the
night okay I gotta go back to my game
that that guy's gonna be in first now
okay but no actually I'm gonna get
points for this too so let's see we're
at oh it's they're disconnected I got 20
more what are the leaders leaders
leaders 157 129 okay oh no Queen night
oh okay be prepared be prepared to be
prepared here we go watch out for watch
out for that castling maneuver it's
lethal it's a killer move it's the it's
the most deadly combination you could
ever have in a chess game the most
deadly without a doubt when you play
okay let's close this up I have f4 now
Knight f4 that's a good spot and what
next okay take this maybe I could get
play queenside castle yeah okay and now
open this position up over here I'm not
gonna play there let's do this let me
get on this file first
okay I'm not afraid over here am i
should I be G file opening up soon I'm
gonna take that or push okay let's get
this night out of there I actually have
a time edge these pawns are being broken
down mate threat move the bishop give me
there's Queen check here and the Queen's
are off let's do this I got the bishop
but they got my rook no they don't okay
they don't have any time they're in
check just push this guy just come back
here and then pre move some stuff where
the premiums right here here's a decent
pre move and here's another one upon
push no mates no mates no mates no mates
what do we got back to tournament one 77
149 am i running away with it despite
two classes uh Selim okay let's go let's
go let's go oh man that's a funny one
and it's definitely funny unbelievable
kingi 1 2 c1 game over that's it I was a
mating 6
okay I gotta try this I can't that
nights gonna sink in there okay now he's
not and I should get my night here
something on this diagonal no I don't
want to trade give a check come back
home and then do this get that Bishop
out of there okay mm-hm
my opponent knows what I have up my
sleeve they've they definitely know
what's going on I want to get rid of the
light square bishop or do i yeah I don't
maybe I shouldn't have done that
um pawn push pawn push undermined the
light squares whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what's happening over here uh-oh
defend here I don't know what that's
doing check Knight moves its mate no
it's not I have to run assume pawn I
should have taken upon okay I have this
right I have that my bishop is defending
rook to g6 made on g7 if my pony isn't
careful rook move here what's happening
with that I'm in check I got to do
something about that I have this
defended my bishop is a good defender
Queen check on e6 they don't have any
time check anything
okay back to tournament 197 169 56 55 54
53 oh I think I have it I think I have
it even if that guy gets some 20 points
oh oh oh here it is here it is watch
here it is boom come on give me the
points I don't have any time oh there it
is again
the killer move king - king to see a TKO
thinking the time it's not gonna finish
by the way look at the clock but if
there was time guess who'd be getting
the W seven six five four three two one
it is completed it's official or is it
give me the confetti oh I had to use
every trick in the book right there
first place confetti a few people had no
idea what hit him or maybe they were
listening to this stream what was going
on if I don't have the Queen rook you
lose it's often it's an automatic I'll
guarantee it every time you gotta watch
out for the Phantom Queen rogue
variation and it's TKO unless you can
stop me from playing what II won to see
one
you lose man that's funny
ah and something will be fixed with that
soon enough
yeah that should definitely be reported
they wouldn't ban me I'm seeing in the
twitch chat ah I'll have to throw in a
message had my fun fit